mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren ich bin wirklich dumm muss man
leider einfach so sagen ich weiß das
ganze eigentlich schon jedoch habe ich
dann einen test im internet entdeckt
namens ist in lucka contractor dumm hier
findest du heraus wie gut du dich mit
lukas dummheit aus kennt ja den habe ich
gefunden und dachte mir den mach ich mal
erste frage luca hat einen führerschein
das ist definitiv war das heißt bisher
bin ich eigentlich gar nicht so dumm
luca dachte früher dass schauspieler
alle sprachen war
ja ich weiß ich war jürgen dormann oder
erfahrenen der straße ist übrigens auch
wieder mit dabei meine damen und herren
der
guckt euch an alte kranke herzlichkeit
einmal luca in meinem gestrigen video
habe ich euch haben eine
weihnachtsgeschenke gezeigt das zweite
geschenk das sie mir geschenkt hat ist
eine tasse mit ihren anfangsbuchstaben
drauf ohne henkel noch mal danke dafür
in dem video habe ich euch auf jeden
fall gefragt wie ich diesen straußen
nennen soll
und da war noch nicht so der perfekteste
name dabei ich weiß da waren über 10.000
kommentare unter dem video aber schreibt
mir jetzt auch hier und in die
kommentare wie eigentlich mehr lokale
passender name für sonnen hässlichen
typen machen wir aber direkt mal
weiterhin mit dem test luca hat früher
immer mit absicht insekten z was nein
falsch alter ich liebe tiere luca hat
früher als er betrunken war gerne kür
ich kann das erklären da steht jetzt so
luca hat kür um geschubst und so das war
nur als wir eines abends bei einem
kumpel müssen was getrunken hatten die
hatten parcours und dann die wahrheit am
schlafen und dann haben wir die halt
aufgeweckt und sind mit denen
rumgelaufen und das hört sich so an als
wäre ich dass ich vom kopf kind war ich
auch so bald sich jetzt jemand beschwert
hey das ist tierquälerei nein ist es
nicht
die schlafen halt einfach im stehen den
chips von jan dort sind die wache und
dann schlafen die weiter summarum juckt
aber im endeffekt niemand da wäre cool
wenn ich diesen straub einfach
und jetzt habe ich eine strauß lampe
nächste frage luca war in der schule
immer zu faul aufs klo zu gehen und hat
sich dann zwei mal in die hose gibt
mir keine schule war ich mit v.li würdig
nein falsch herbert was denken die sich
dann aber gut nächste frage sogar kann
nicht kochen austauscht ag das ist war
in letzter zeit koche ich ein bisschen
mehr allerdings konnte ich lange zeit
wirklich nie mehr als passt also
wirklich kochen aber es war die beste
pasta in ganz köln
luca hat sich früher mal auf dem
schulhof gemault und ist dann in
hundescheiße gefallen
wer hat sich dieses quick mir der hat
sich das ausgedacht menschen ziemlich
abstoßen also das stimmt auch nicht ich
bin noch nie den hundescheiße gefallen
ich bin schon oft in hundescheiße
getreten locker 20 mal irgendwie zieht
das magisch an
im januar hundescheiße getreten scheiße
scheiße passt ja in der tat aber ich
habe mich noch nie gemacht und bin einen
hundescheiße gefallen nächste frage luca
war mal bei einem freund und hab dann
aus versehen sein spülbecken kaputt
gemacht und hat es einem freundlich
gesagt
das ist keine schöne frage wie macht man
ein spülbecken kaputt das ist natürlich
auch falsch luca hat sich mein
handgelenk verstaucht und ist dann zum
arzt gegangen der arzt ist ein
handgelenk dann erst gebrochen
das war ja das war mehr oder weniger war
die sache ist aber ich weiß gar nicht
was das für ein komischer test ist ich
hatte in meiner hand verstaucht und das
tat schon ein bisschen weh und er atmete
aller bankkunden als noch mehr weh getan
ja dann hatte ich ein verband und jetzt
ist einigermaßen wieder heile welt
sicherlich mein wohlbefinden sorgen
macht mir geht es gut aber es macht sich
keiner sorgen man wohl befinden
lukas erstes instagram bild ist ein bild
das er selbst gemalt hat mit absicht
hässlich
mehr was mein erstes bild des aber ich
habe noch nie eigentlich fast gemalt auf
instagram luca hat früher am anfang von
seinen videos immer hallo ihr schlingel
gtf nein luca ist der beste youtuber da
würde ich einfach mal auf war klicken
wir kriegen jetzt mal auf die auswertung
und wir sehen alles
oh mein gott wer fas
die kamera da hinten gefallen alles
richtig alter leute
ist das
jetzt ich bin dumm oder nicht dumm um
das herauszufinden meine damen und
herren hab ich selbst wahrscheinlich
noch einen zweiten test rausgesucht er
heißt einfach ist konkreter dummen liebe
freunde an alle die das quiz machen das
ist alles aus humor ich bin ein fan von
ihm und er ist einfach mein idol
ich weiß nicht wie ich vollidioten idol
von jemandem sein kann aber in ordnung
wir fangen mal an mit der ersten frage
ist luca dumm
chris vorbei die antwortmöglichkeiten
werden noch nie juckt mich einen scheiß
wäre es eigentlich luca und hast du
ahnung wer albert einstein ist das ist
finde ich eine ganz gute antwort zweite
frage was würdest du machen wenn du luca
sehen würdest hingehen foto machen
unterschriften und den tag genießen nix
das würde ich machen hingehen und sagen
du bist dumm wer ist überhaupt denn luca
und jetzt sagt auch wer albert einstein
war das ist wieder die richtige antwort
wie viele abos hatten sogar über zwei
millionen 0 juckt einem der ist fame
geil wer ist jetzt auf einmal logar
ausgezeichnet dicker wäre albern also
das frage ich mich halt immer noch hier
wird gefragt wo ich wohne köln
düsseldorf dortmund aber noch keinen
plan will ich nicht wissen wer ist jetzt
wieder auf einmal luca meine fresse wer
es einmal einstein das also dass das
interessiert uns sehr am nächste frage
ist konkreter cool nee nee nee und auf
einmal contractor wer ist konkreter wer
war albert einstein soll ja spielt
konrad oft minecraft wie immer
dann war auf zeit möchte das ganze doch
noch einmal auf zeit ein paar sekunden
später als man hat wirklich nur zwei
minuten zeit für diesen test wir hatten
ja bisher immer nur albert einstein
gefragt spiel kommt oft minecraft dabei
waren wir nähen immer so oft ja juckt
wer ist denn jetzt wieder kräfte ich
mach juckt
vor allem hier steht kein crafter und
hier steht konrad r
louis bester freund max ja schreibt mal
gescheit wie wir es mal brennt oder wer
als albert einstein hat würde ich eher
dann sogar nehmen hat luca ukulele ja
luca wieder geschrieben hey wer war noch
einmal ukulele seinen fuß ja das meine
damen und herren das ist mein fußball
kriegen möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen muss mich ein bisschen beeilen
interessiert doch niemanden wäre es
jetzt auf einmal luca entscheidet ich
mal krimi www erst einmal arm immer
wieder das hier ist das die letzte frage
von lobbys test nähe ja jetzt doch
keinem lewis durfte heißt er luca luka
oder luke evans albert einstein logi
acht der heilige stuhl kommen die ganzen
kommentare sind ich sage hier wieder wer
es einmal einstein und die letzte frage
war der luca test geil jahr hat mir
gefallen ehe ich glaube ich habe alles
falsch geantwortet definitiv nein wer
ist eigentlich dieser luca jetzt meine
fresse und natürlich die letzte antwort
na gut dann google ich wär albert
einstein ist aber ich werde nie
vergessen dass du so was gemeint ist
gemacht hast das nehmen wir natürlich
aber auch schon die auswertung kommt es
zu bekommen meine damen und herren des
kontraktes um die entscheidende frage
die unseren heutigen
da wirst du ja genau so konnten nichts
ändern
mit dem ergebnis ja ich glaube dass
beantwortet dann die frage ob ich dumm
bin an der stelle meine lieben freunde
würde ich das heutige video hat
allerdings auch beenden ich habe mir
eigentlich noch zwei weitere christus
rausgesucht einmal bist du so doof wie
luca und bist du für die kontrakte luca
cod keine ahnung warum sie jetzt
eigentlich ein ballerspiel aber okay
wenn ich also auf diese beiden tests die
ich mir noch ausgesucht habe in einem
anderen video eventuell mal beantworten
soll dann lasst 40.000 leichter 40.000
eine große zahl also gebt den daumen
hoch wenn euch das video hier gefallen
hat und ich das gleiche quasi noch mal
mit anderen quiz machen soll und
schreibe mir wie bereits gesagt
unbedingt in die kommentare die visa
dessert
immer wenn ich den sie gerne das ist ja
echt der hardcore hässlich schreibt mir
unbedingt in die kommentare wie er hier
heißt es
ich hab einen namen
logi albert 1 die fäden der sieht halt
wegen den haaren sogar so ein bisschen
so aussieht her stimmt da ich hier weg
gefragt werde wie ich selbst überhaupt
genannt werden will hier meine aussage
dazu ist mir scheißegal ich will ehrlich
gesagt nur schlafen und pizza fressen
also lasst mich in ruhe ihre pizza also
wie soll dieser strauß wir heizen
freunde ihr dürft entscheiden schreibt
wir gerne und in die kommentare in logie
baird 1 den oder komplett anders lasten
like dabei dem video und abonniert main
kanal
[Musik]